[Music]
thank you very much um yeah so as Robert
already mentioned uh my name is yis
apologies to those expecting Chris here
um I hope I don't disappoint too much
but uh yeah I'll I'll try to do my best
to to go through the the slides that
Chris Chris prepared the slides so
that's at least that's at least
something right um I'll give an advanced
warning right I'm not not too into the
lowle details here but I should be able
to to guide you all through the uh
through the presentation so we ask any
questions if you have them after the
fact all right so um my name is Yus as
mentioned uh I am the technical team
lead of for Julia Sim um when it comes
to applications and um um turning it
into a product so Julie Sim is our
simulation environment model based for
model base engineering based on top of
Julia um it's a proprietary project uh
product developed by Julia hub
so just quick intro into Julia um I
guess most people have at least heard
about it um who's using Julia just quick
show of
hands Ah that's not bad um so quickly
just like what is Julia for those that
like have never heard of it uh so Julia
is a high level language uh it's been
around for about well 12 years now um
was announced in uh at Valentine's Day
2012 um so it's been around for a while
the it went 1.0 in in 2018 so it's been
sort of at a stable um stable versioning
rate ever since um so Julia is a high
level programming language that was
described as by by the creators you know
they made a new program language because
they were greedy so they wanted
everything right they wanted speed they
wanted uh high high expressivity they
just want to have a language that was
nice to work with but could compare
basically could just tear through data
just run really well um that was its
original cell I think there's right
Julia is indeed a fast language that's
something you'll hear people talk about
a lot
um but it's a lot more right it gives
the the I think once you start using it
for for a long time there are a lot of
other benefits that sort of become
apparent some of which will'll see um
during these uh this presentation as
well so you can see here compared to
some other languages right julus sits
basically at the bottom left which means
that it's a highly expressive language
um but it's also very fast um so you get
the best of both worlds who doesn't want
that uh and I think one particularly
interesting thing is relative to um to
more traditional high level languages
right where you have they're very nice
to Pro prototype in right this is why
people use things like Matlab python
they're very nice to prototyp is very
nice to express your IDE ideas that you
have typically around scientific
research or engineering um but then when
you want to make things fast you have to
move into other languages like C or
Fortran to to get really speed benefits
of being able to to Crunch through your
data fast or to to solve in this case
solve equations
um quickly um so the the one of the nice
things at least I think about Julia is
that you can actually get the best of
both worlds but you can get there
incrementally right you can write slow
Julia code actually there's a lot of it
will be a lot of people's first
experience is when you just started
writing Julia and you start writing it
as if you were writing python or math
lab you go wait this is actually
slow which is okay right you can still
express your ideas and then over time
you can actually add um what when you
learn how to make faster or you can dig
into the details of what makes Julie a
bit faster and you can start add adding
type information things like that to
incrementally get better improve uh
better working soft or faster working
software um so you have the Julie
Community it's or well it's basically
Julia in numbers right we we're steadily
growing this goes back to about 2016 as
I mentioned it's was announced in 201 I
started 2014 um 1.0 in 2018 so you can
see everything's steadily growing
basically there there's lots of more and
more video content available on YouTube
uh downloads keep
Rising uh the community forums get more
and more active and we this year we
actually crossed the 10,000 packages I'm
hope I'm not I'm standing in front of
the uh slide so I'll move move out of
the way a bit uh we crossed the 10,000
package um number
so as I mentioned right often one of the
the nice benefits cited for Julia is
that you sort of you get these highlevel
programming language benefits without
having to go to lowle languages right if
you look in the in the python community
and you look like or in the python
ecosystem you look at things like scipi
or numpy um the high level interfaces
are are are nice and in Python but as
soon as you have to get into performance
critical code you have to go into C or
or or Fortran and you're you're calling
into libraries like that um which is
fine right that's a design decision one
of the downsides of that is that if you
if you are working on something right
and you want to first get
started as soon as you hit a hit a point
where you need more performance and you
know python well now you also need to
know C right which is that's a
significant where there's two different
ecosystems that you now have to know
about
so what if we use Julia and its
numerical packages um as a back end for
python on r instead right so one of the
advantages that that would give you is
that you would actually get a lower
entry to be where you still need to
learn another language if you wanted
that however that is another highlevel
language so you can still express your
ideas in the um in this higher level
language um without having to for
performance reasons go into this into
sea level code or or forun and change
into a different ecosystem um one of the
particularly nice things I've seen
quoted a couple of times when it comes
to the Julia ecosystem is actually that
there is a large when it comes to
something like the differ equations
package uh or that ecosystem there are a
lot of contributors and this comes from
the fact that a lot of people come in
from their own sort of distinct areas of
expertise and they need something uh
that's numerically faster or more stable
and actually can contribute that the the
the barrier to contributing code to the
core ecosystem of differential equations
is very low because they know Julia so
they can very easily contribute like new
algorithms things like that back and
they don't even necessarily have to
worry about performance because well
I've been in the community for J
Community for a while and I know people
pretty easily get nerd sniped so if you
just go this isn't fast enough or you
know why is my python package faster I
guarantee you someone will go in and you
know sort of optimize everything for you
which is nice you know you don't have to
learn C you don't even have to learn how
to write perform and Julia just have
someone else do it for
you now the Julie Community has been
growing for a while so there's a large
set of existing tools um when it comes
to numerical packages and there's a
quite large developer Community I think
i' I've seen numbers for the the the
particular packages I'll be talking
about today of that we end up with about
like 100 contributors um not all of them
active all the time of course but
there's a there's a fairly stantive
amount of people that are working on
things like different differential
equation solvers and just other packages
in the larger um siml ecosystem well
siml ecosystem you ask what is that well
let's dive into that a bit um so what
we'll primarily be focused on during
this talk is um a subset of that right
which is about high performance
differentiable uh equation
solvers um so the scl ecosystem is we'll
dig into a bit later what siml is we'll
keep it a bit vague for now um but
basically what we have is and this is
one of the strengths of Julia is Julia
packages are very composable so it's
very easy if if someone else has written
a package right you if you know things
like open close principle and stuff like
that if you're into software engineering
it's very easy if someone has provided
like base
types for or or function right it has
defined certain functions like solve
right this is how you or or types for
that will help you solve linear uh
systems of linear equations it's very
easy to reuse those and um expand on
them as well with new algorithms and
things like that so there's the siml
ecosystem gives this has this this basis
of a number of of packages that tackle
specific numerical issues like linear
solving linear equations nonlinear
equations uh solving differential
equations just regular optimization but
they all tie in neatly together and this
is where a lot of the strength of this
ecosystem comes from is that people go
like oh I have this piece here what if
and I have this this sort of
optimization strategy here can I combine
them easily typically the answer is yes
and if not it'll take you like you know
10 lines of code but it's typically very
easy if an integration doesn't exist yet
to add
it so one of the key things that people
always bring up when we're talking about
differential differential equation
solvers um within Julia is that they are
really really fast um typically they sit
at the bottom of this these types of
graphs um so one thing I want to point
out here if you're if you know if you
disagree and go like wait my why is my
thing so slow um there's this uh well I
I guess the QR code up there leads to it
but you can see there's this this scl
benchmarks repository so all of these
benchmarks are completely open so if you
disagree or you want to add a new solver
um file a PO request right it's
it's these benchmarks are continuously
um expanded upon so basically to keep an
eye to make sure that they are as Fair
as possible so you don't get into
arguments on blog posts about but you
did X wrong it's like well if you did X
wrong you know a faster implementation
go ahead Everything is Everything is
available um but what that means is we
end up with um different equation
solvers that are like 50 times faster
than scipi or ma lab or up to 100 times
faster than D solve in R um so that
would be nice right if these are like
ordered two orders of magn
speed improvements what if we could use
those easily in so that's what we're
talking about when we use those in
within python now it's not just about
speed um as I mentioned right there's
this broad community of of people that
are contributing to this so that means
that you get um a lot of like
state-of-the-art algorithms in these
packages as well it's very easy to try
out different types of solvers on on the
same if if you want to try something new
it's very easy to implement something
new without actually having to change
like the the overall problem description
that you're um the problem that you're
trying to solve right because they they
all R all of these implementations rely
on these interface packages that just
you know what do you need to know how to
solve a system of differential equations
well just call the solve function on it
right and then you just go um there's a
bunch of different types of solvers
there are just some that are more stable
in certain cases for certain types of of
problems um there are solvers that can
deal with sto stochasticity in um in the
differential equations I'm not even
going to talk about aded joins because I
have no idea what they are
um um and one of the key benefits I
think that we'll we'll see a bit later
as well is um they can actually be
parallelized pretty well or well
extremely well actually um which has its
own brings along a whole different set
of benefits so for instance um it's
trivial to run these solvers on on gpus
is actually one of the key benefits of
Julia it's it's very easy if you have
something that works on a CPU it it it
typically requires like literally a
couple of lines being change to a
different type right so instead of an
array you use a Cuda array and now
things run on your GPU um and this means
you can get messes speed improvements um
and the Beautiful Thing here as well is
that this doesn't just work uh for Cuda
uh this works for AMD this works for for
one API and even as Chris always likes
to say um he he got you know an M1 Mac
especially so he could could put this
additional bar on the side of this graph
even though it's not that impressive but
what is impressive that it just works
it's it's not if you if you want to if
you have a different GPU you're not
writing we're not writing um specific
implementations of a solver for a
specific GPU now we can take
implementations of certain data types
that are optimized for a specific GPU
architecture and combine that with the
solvers that are defined in the siml
ecosystem and then so it's very easy to
switch around and and compare across
different platforms as
well um one of the recent advancements
um something that people have been
talking about at least as long as I know
about it which has been you know web I
always say web assembly has been the
promise for about a decade now um we're
finally seeing things happen that way a
bit um but a large we we actually able
right now as of I think as of a couple
of months ago on like the most recent
versions of chrome and by recent I mean
the ones that aren't released yet um
because you need garbage collection I
believe that's the thing that's
necessary which isn't wasn't available
in web assembly until a couple months
ago um we can even take at very least
subsets of the differential equations
ecosystem and compile them into web
assembly so they just run natively in
your browser so that makes it very easy
to basically go from from your research
phase right into that's I think a very
important part here as well is you
you're in your high level language you
can you have a very expressive language
to do your research in but then when you
want to bring it to production you're
not handing it over again and again and
again right before I joined Julia Hub I
was working for for a different company
I think we had like four stages there
where you know someone was doing
something in math lab that would get
Rewritten in fix point that would get
Rewritten in C and then some parts would
probably even get Rewritten in assembly
that's a huge uh train to follow through
there a huge supply chain to go through
and there's a large opportunity for
arist to creep in that's less of an
issue when you're when you're going with
Julia because you can stay within Julia
and you can take it all the way down to
machine code so yeah that's that's about
it on what I wanted to say about um the
differential equations ecosystem in the
Julia language itself so can we get all
this nice stuff in in R and python if if
that's what you want and obviously the
answer here is yes otherwise I wouldn't
be giving this talk um so here we
actually have three um three examp or
well it's the same example in in in
three languages um Chris I'm not sure
how old the packages are I believe they
actually have been around for a bit but
so um the time system has a DQ pi and
dqr packages which are wrappers around
the different equations ecosystem in
Julia so on on the left here we have an
example of the Lawrence equations in
Julia right so you define a function
with uh with the derivatives keeping
track of the derivatives and the input
uh it doesn't use parameters or or time
here um you can set you set that up you
you convert it into a problem and then
you solve the problem right this is this
is what basically any of these problem
any of these things looks like typically
the majority of work sits in your in the
definition of your
model now with the DQ pi and dqr
packages we can actually well you can
see it's almost one to one right there
obviously there there's some some L
synthetic sugar here and there and
there's some slight language changes but
what happens here is that under the hood
right this this gets translated into uh
this is Maps directly onto the Julia
types um so you get already some some
nice benefits you can it's even easy to
to move back and forth between right
well you have to still rewrite it a bit
but you can probably get things pretty
close um it gets even better though
right because one of the things that you
typically have to do is if you're using
a different language like C or forra now
you have an entire different tool tool
chain to spin up which typically can
come with its own dis or rate its own
challenges now you have to maintain two
things or div verions compatible it's eh
it's no fun right I've been there uh
these particular packages they actually
give provide full automation here so
they have an not sure why they call
differently I didn't write it uh they
have a setup and an install method that
will just automatically install Julia
make sure that right things are
installed correct packages um you know
nicely isolated so they don't mess up
your system um and this also
automatically sets up these necessary
conversions right that you need to move
between Python and and Julia Julia in
general is quite good at this um there
are a couple there are many packages
that provide Integrations between these
different languages uh you have them for
python R Java there's but these are
typically just binding of turning or C
even right to turn one data type
specific to one language into another
one
um so if you're building software for
other people they don't even have to
know that under the hood it's Julia
right they don't have to set up anything
additional you just call that one
function in your in your code and you're
good to
go now I have to be honest I don't
completely understand what Chris wanted
to do with this talk or with this
particular slide um well I I think I do
so forgive me if I'm wrong the um so as
people may know Julia is a jit compiled
language just just in time compiled and
because this code in Python and R that
you see actually gets translated into
Jew right it gets turned into Julia
under the hood you get these same jit
benefits because Julia takes care of the
Just in Time compilation um and then we
we have our own so there's a modeling
toolkit which is our uh modeling
language in Julia um we can do all sort
of cool symbolic stuff to to simplify
models and stuff like that to to get rid
of extran equations making sure if
things are stable even before
calculating
anything so just sort of a quick
analysis of of where we have these
different performance overheads in the
in this package or um right when when
calculating differential equations so um
and it's again it's been a while since I
took a class on differential equations
so I lost a lot of lost a lot of
knowledge
there um but it's relatively easy this
is from a a paper by uh Elizabeth rush
and I don't know the other people
um if you're if you're trying to solve
this set of differential equations right
this amounts to and this is where the
sort of the speed up comes from it's
just putting it down into numbers we're
capable of taking these operations and
just fuse them into a single function
call inside Julia basically this
modeling toolkit and everything around
it is a sort of an additional compiler
on top of the Julia compiler um so we
can perform all sorts of analyses while
we're building the code for you that
actually gets
executed um so in on this just ends up
being eight function calls in Number the
fusion happens as well and then we can
take you can take a look at the the how
expensive it is to to call a function to
call the final function and that gives
you like about a 30 uh 30 times speed up
in in Julia Julia code just executes
faster um theoretically of course um but
this means you can as you can see at the
bottom right you can you can get some
pretty Extreme Performance benefits over
solving differential equation systems in
Julia versus directly in python or even
using
number um
so again similar to what I what I said
earlier right the um the siml benchmarks
ecosystem if you you can it's on the QR
code um the the the there are notebooks
collab notebooks or Google cab notebooks
available that actually just run this in
um where you can run this interactively
and ins for yourself that it's actually
fast
um so yeah these are quite impressive
numbers right whether you you have to
wait for a week or or half a day
is give me half the day well give me an
hour preferably but just a lot right
faster feed feedback loops are always
better and I'll stick with that um but
the real nice thing right as I as I
talked about earlier we have this GPU
support and as Chris calls it right
that's the real part of trick is can we
leverage this GPU acceleration that's
inside Julia from Python and R and the
answer is well yes um and again
similarly to what we had just for the
overall um integration of of dqp and dqr
is there's there are setup methods that
will just specifically install the
drivers that you need which you
typically don't want to always ship
right not sure anybody has ever checked
how large Cuda drivers are
but they're big they're like one and a
half gigabytes right nowadays um so you
don't want to ship that to everybody
especially if they're not using it um so
again this also just automatically
installs all the Julia Julia packages
and you're just good to go you have full
automation of the GPU acceleration
process from Julia for python
andr uh and again right it's not just
Julia or it's not just Cuda uh if you
want you can if you have an AMD GPU just
import whatever package is specific or
whatever module is specific to your uh G
the GPU in your machine and it'll just
work um I don't know right I I'm not
familiar with the ecosystems but
according to Chris these might be the
first packages that are GPU agnostics in
GPU agnostic in these
ecosystems
um I think we still I don't know what
the difference is here oh yeah this is
the jit performance uh so for Kuda R so
this again compared to Pythor and Jax
same
story a lot faster so you you you
mentioned this sign or I mentioned this
sign you might go like you mentioned
this scl What's siml um as actually well
I kind of enjoy it I think it's quite
nice idea um so what about siml stands
for scientific machine learning what
does it actually mean right so you
always have these sort of two camps
nowadays in in when it comes to um to
solving problems is either your or well
those are two extremes right you're
either in the data Camp you could just
go I can do anything with data or you're
in the hardcore I can model anything or
try to model anything camps
siml says well you know why there's
there are downsides to both right you if
you need to learn everything from data
that's throwing away a lot of knowledge
that you have um and you can't typically
um put anything everything in your
equations because it just becomes
intractable to to solve so this is
actually what uh what the SEL EOS is all
about right it allows us to capture
knowledge that we have right things we
know just from
physics um use that to to to build
models to to to to to solve those models
to even perform control on them and then
aend those models with machine
learning based on real data that we
obtain from real systems um to get to a
space where we can get to better overall
models um so as an example right uh say
that we have a a a physical model that
we know like this describes a certain
phenomenon um but the things that we
measure turns out they're they're not
accurate at all now what you could do of
course is you could try to um change the
parameters of your your known physics to
to get there what you can also do or
what what we do typically in um in siml
is we we add an error term which
basically we we slap a neural net
at the end and then we use we we put
that inside a simulator we solve for the
O OD system and now because you have the
real world data we you can train sort of
the missing error parts right the parts
that you didn't know but that are are
apparently there in your data but that
weren't described by your physical
system uh can automatically learn what
those what those pieces are and then uh
thereby basically find you in your model
and there's a lot of sort of this is
very basic but there are a lot of cool
edge cases that you can can do with this
as well so one of one example here is
this this doesn't necessarily seem like
something that's easy to learn um but
say that and I again not an expert so
forgive me um right this is um a model
or this is data obtained from the uh two
black holes right that
that rotate around each other and so you
can sort of what Happ what we're we're
doing here or what we've done what has
been done here is sort of only describe
like regular physics and L like you
don't know anything about Rel uh
relativity Theory which I don't I don't
know that much so that makes sense um
but what we can actually do is we we
have gathered right or this this group
has gathered a large amount of data from
uh the ligo gravitational wave data um
what they can actually do is they can
you can start with your your regular
physical description and actually use
the data that you've learned or that you
have obtained for relatively small piece
um and reconstruct sort of the
relativistic terms that need to be added
on top of your your your regular um
physical description to learn and you
can see that these things are right so
we the the blue line is the true a known
waveform the the dotted red is the
Learned but we can learn this well
relatively complex interaction of these
of these two black holes from a very
relatively small amount of
data
which is is very nice right this means
there's a ton of examples if you go to S
ll. is is the website there ton of
examples here that actually go into like
chem chemical processes that are where
you would if you would just know or if
you just try to model the data you
didn't know anything about the
underlying physics you would be you
would try to extrapolate you would be
completely wrong um but using this
combination you can actually make
correct
predictions um
so again I don't sorry I don't know too
much about this one particularly but I'm
sure other people do uh you can also
integrate Julia code and dyq Pi with py
torge um that's all I have to say about
it I'm sorry so there are obviously
right there are some caveats to to using
something like this um there is
obviously a performance overhead right
you're you have to translate from one
language into the other right you have
to translate data types so there's some
performance overhead but even with that
performance overhead it's still faster
than all the other implementation so you
know yeah it's overhead but it doesn't
matter if it still faster not really um
the automatic differentiation support
does not have nice syntax right now um
that those are things that can be ironed
out um yeah and the jits Very because as
I sort of talking about there sort of a
compiler on top of a compiler type
situation uh there are the the jit is
restricted to just the mathematical
operations that can be handled by
modeling toolkit by this by this
modeling language and its corresponding
compiler uh but those are I'm not sure
if those are things are getting changed
they might not be able to well well
there's just some fundamental things
right things that aren't in Julia you
can't sort
of the influence stops somewhere um so
if you really want to go all in just use
Julia well I have to say that I work for
Julia Hub um but if you want to just get
started just even just compare to what's
what's possible um anyone in the
scientific Community can basically step
in and start exploring these ideas
through the dqp and
dqr
packages so
yeah about time so that's it thank
you thank you so much if there's
questions from the room please uh raise
your
hand
yeah go
ahead Julia jul kind of more or
so uh yeah so the question is um
obviously right there there's a sort of
competitive nature to this and then sort
of the integration provides this wolf
and sheep you know we're trying to steal
people away sort of idea from from other
communities um I I I get that that's a
sentiment right that that um that
happens and then well and then sort of
the followup question is you know how
how do people from the RN python
communities adopt these um adopt to
Julia
um I think as as as a lot of these cases
go right it's it's a very F viseral sort
of reaction right these things almost
become religious right it's where um
there are quite a few people that have
indeed gone like well I just can't do
these things and are or it doesn't or in
python or it doesn't feel right um so
sometimes people do get put off by sort
of as I mentioned right the there is a
different style of programming if you're
going into like deep into Julia like if
I could compare how I wrote Julia code
or if how I wrote code a decade ago
versus how I write Julia code now be due
to the facilities that the language
gives you uh you're basically your mind
you know you think about problems in a
different way because it allows you to
express Pro to express the things that
you have in a different way so for some
people that really clicks right and and
sometimes you might need some guidance
to actually to actually get there um and
so yeah you can still get that sort of
split where you go i' I've met met many
people that went like okay so I tried
you know I have my python or my math lab
or our model turned it into Julia and I
basically just you know literally
translated it and it's slow so I'm going
to give up well yeah that you have those
um and on the other hand yeah you do
have people that are full converts um
one thing I think that is beneficial to
things like this where if you which I
used to be one of right I I was a fullon
Julia convert um but within
um within a group of people that was
only writing math lab and was never
going to change right but you still want
to do it's like but I can't do these
things in this other language so I have
to sort
of do it this other way so then having
these types of things available where
you can integrate with other languages
is just it's just very
nice that answer your
question question but Julia promised all
of us that we would not need a second
language and right now Julia solving not
a second language problem but n language
problem and kind of substitute for you
saying okay we a lot of people like typ
and python we cannot do anything about
it and we will at least compile their
code in Julia not
in It's
Kind
from well I think so yeah so the the
idea the question is right one of the
things that Julia or the Julia Community
talks about a lot is this idea of a two
language problem right the sort of the
high level language versus lowlevel
language and having packages like these
sort of feels like we're sort of giving
up on that right if I'm paraphrasing you
correctly um I see that right I I I I
get it I I'm not sure if that's
necessarily entirely accurate um it's
also about as I sort of said mentioned
earlier right it is about being able to
sometimes you there's a you have a might
have a huge Legacy Pro huge Legacy uh
code base or model base or whatever
right and you need to you can't rewrite
everything from scratch so for cases
like that or for just for people that
are interested in being able to compare
things um I think that's the primary
purpose of of having packages like these
to facilitate this integration um with
other communities to also be able to
bring additional uh expertise into the
into the into the larger ecosystem and
Community think we have time for one
quick question maybe still and then we
need to uh close there's anything
else if not then uh thank you very much
your for stepping in so late I think we
can all agree that you did a great job
and uh yeah please give him another very
big round of
[Applause]
applause thank you oh I'm I'm turning up
and I and I and I have stickers if
anyone wants
them
[Music]
obviously